[موسيقى]
هذا كلام منطقي على العربيه بودكاست وانا
راويه العلمي
هل لاحظت فكره انه كل مجموعه من الناس ايا
كانت وبغض النظر عن نوع او تعليم او ثقافه
او خلفيه اجتماعيه او طبقه مجتمعيه او او
دائما ما بتحوي شخص معين هذا الشخص دائما
بكون صاحب نظريه المؤامره غالبا ما بيكون
ماده سهله للفكاهه هو دائما متوجس وكانه
حقا يعلم شيء او اشياء يبدو انه احنا
جميعا اخفقنا في ملاحظتها
السيناريو لدى صاحبنا هذا دوما مرتبط
بالمشتبه بهم وهو دوما ما بشير لالهم
بهؤلاء فالصحه المتدهوره هي من صنع هؤلاء
سواء كان الموضوع مرتبط بالسرطانات
المنتشره اللي بدنا نسمع عنها بتواتر اكبر
من اي وقت مضى او الجائحه المسمى بكوفيد
واللي ما بين ليله وضحاها يبدو وكانها
اختفت واسعار الادويه طبعا المرتفعه
والاسره الممتلئه في المستشفيات كل مصائب
الدنيا كلها امور بتحصل نتيجه للتخطيط
الشيطاني لهؤلاء طيب ماذا عن اسعار
الاغذيه المرتفعه او الاقتصادات المتدهوره
والاعلام واخبار المزيفه كلها برضه من صنع
هؤلاء
اعتقد انكم عرفتوا صاحبنا هذا داخل محيطكم
الاجتماعي فهو يا اما فرد من عائلتكم او
جاركم في شارعكم او هذا الزميل في العمل
وانتو وبدون ادنى شك يمكن شاركتوا في
النيل منه بالنكات مرارا وتكرارا
لكن ماذا لو قلت لكم انه هذا الشخص ممكن
فعلا انه يكون على حق وانه ممكن انه احنا
جميعا مخطئين هل اثرت انتباهكم طيب جاروني
لا بس بضع دقائق خليني احاول اني اسلط
الضوء على موضوع طرحت افكاره سابقا بشكل
كبير لكن لسبب ما ما بتوصلنا الرساله وهذا
بحد ذاته بصراحه غريب ومريب قبل ما ندخل
في تفاصيل حلقتنا اعزائي المتابعين بحب
اني ارحب بضيفي من عمان علي بن مسعود
المعشني الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
اهلا وسهلا فيك استاذ علي معنا في كلام
منطقي حياكم الله واتمنى ان نكون مفيد
وخفيف ان شاء الله اكيد
اسمح لي ابدا معك استاذ علي بسؤال عام بعض
الشيء موضوع حلقه هذا اليوم عن يعني نظريه
المؤامره فيما يتعلق بالشركات اللي مسيطره
على العالم وبتحكم العالم نوعا ما هي
الشركات تندرج تحت عده فئات منها شركات
طبيه وشركات يعني المواد الاستهلاكيه او
اعلاميه او غيره ولكن لو حكينا في نظريه
المؤامره نفسها صار في نوع من انواع
الوصمه لهذه النظريه ولكل الناس اللي نوعا
ما بايدوها وبيامنوا فيها ولكن في المقابل
هناك خطر من انه
نقوم
بضحد او عدم الاهتمام باي شيء ممكن يندرج
تحت نظريه المؤامره لانه احنا هيك ممكن
نغفل معلومات ونغفل عن
بعض الامور اللي كتير كتير مهمه واللي
ممكن تاذينا وتاثر على حياتنا بشكل مباشر
كيف ممكن
ما بين هذا الترند بانه نظريه المؤامره هو
شيء سيء وناس معينين بذهنيه وعقليه معينه
هن اللي بيامنوا فيها وما بين نكون حويطين
على علم ودرايه بما يجري حوالينا
من النظريه والفرضيه هي امور يقلب فيها
الراي وجهه نظر
لذلك لما يقول لك نظريه الحكم ولا فرضيه
السياسه ولا كذا اشياء غير قاطعه احنا
عندنا في الشارع حاجه قطعيه الدلاله وحاجه
ظنيه الدلاله
نظريه المؤامره هذه قد تكون في بعض
الاحيان ظنيه الدلاله يعني تختلف منه الى
قد تكون احيانا تبريريا للبعض التبرير
عجزه وفشله قد تكون
ولكن في بعض الاشياء بنشوفها امامنا الان
بالنسبه للغرب وخاصه حكومه
ما تسبب المليار الذهبي فهي قطعيه الدلاله
لما جاءت الازمه الاوكرانيه يعني مش كشفت
لبشت وعرت كل شيء
يعني هذا المساله لا تحتاج الاجتهاد
لاجتهاد مع الناس يا راويه في بعض
وعندما ناتي الى نحن كعربهم مسلمين فانا
اعتقد كما يقول الكثير مش الكثير للاسف
القله منه بان من ينكر نظريه المؤامره على
العرب والمسلمين العرب بالدرجه الاولى
كحاض للاسلام العربي حاضن الحضاره العربيه
الاسلاميه فهو شريك في المؤامره من ينكر
المؤامره فهو شريك في المؤامره طب اسمح لي
هلا في ناس ممكن يقولوا بانه احنا دائما
العرب منعلق فشلنا على شماعه المؤامره
هناك مؤامره تحاك ضدنا نحن بينما يعني
يمكن اذا بنطلع على الموضوع وهذا اللي
بحاول ابينه بهاي الحلقه هو الموضوع اوسع
واعمق واكبر بكثير من العالم العربي ومن
المسلمين فقط يعني اذا كان هناك نظريات
مؤامره ليش بدنا نكون احنا تحديدا
المستهدفين يعني ومش العالم كله ويمكن هذا
هو الحقيقه وهذا هو اللي حاصل فبالتالي
بصير نوع من
يعني فكره نظريه المؤامره خصوصا لما تكون
مستهدف العرب والمسلمين تفقد مصداقيتها
لما يكون هذا هو هدفها وتكون محدده بهذا
الاطار رابع في ناس في فلسطين الان
يعتقدوا ان احتلال فلسطين
كانوا فيها عريضه جدا يعتقدون بالاحتلال
الفرنسي فهمتي هو قضاء وقدر من الله لا
يجوز رده لا يجوز ما هو بفعل الانسان يعني
بل في طائفه موجوده من الطوائف الصوفيه
الرحمانيه يسمونهم كان يعتقدون انه فرنسا
ولي امر لا يجوز محاربتها طالما لم تنهيك
عن الصلاه
التبريرات واسعه جدا واللغه واسعه جدا
ولكن يبقى الحق هنا والباطل هنا هذا ما في
قسمه على اثنين احنا جزء صح من نظريه
المؤامره في هذا العالم ليس المستهدفين
ولكن جهد المعركه انتبه على الوطن العربي
ما احب استخدمه في العالم لانه ما في
حميميه مصطلح اوروبي هذه ما يعجبني احنا
الوطن العربي هم دول عربي ومش عارف اقطار
عربي كان في يعني عباره عن مدن في كيان
جغرافي واحد جهد المعركه كما يسمى
بالمصطلح العسكري على الوطن العربي ليه
شوفي الخارطه شوفي قلب العالم لماذا زرعت
ما يسمى باسرائيل في الوطن العربي ولم
تزرع في اوغندا لما كان مقترح لماذا لم
تزرع في اوكرانيا كما يقولون الان انه هي
فلسطين السماويه الموعوده لماذا لم تزرع
في استراليا وهي ارض ماهوله بنسبه 10% فقط
اذا يراد تعطيل هذا الامه واستخدام
الفيديو ضدها وتبقى هذا يبقى هذا الكيان
يراضي الغريب اللي فيه يسعى الى التطبيع
والسلام وكذا كيان لا حدود له هل هي هذه
كل هذا الكلام يعني يعود لكل دوله وكل
دوله بتقرر ما هو في مصلحتها وبتعمل عليه
ولا يعني
كيف بدنا نقول
كل دوله بالفعل اذربي بمصلحتها ولا يمكن
اليوم عليها اذا كان هذا يصب في اطار
مصالحها على كل حال انا بدي اوسع الدائره
اكثر وبدي احاول انه ما ندخل كثير فيما
يتعلق بالسياسه وعلاقتها بنظريه المؤامره
اعلم يعني كل العلم بانه صعب الفصل بينهم
ولكن انا عم بحاول اوسع دائره نقاشنا ما
هو اكبر من ذلك لانه هي المؤامره مش بس
فيما يتعلق بالموضوع السياسي او على الاقل
يعني بعد بحث لكتابه واعداد هذه الحلقه
الموضوع بتغلغل بكل مناحي حياتنا وليس فقط
السياسه اذا بتسمح لي تبقى معنا خليني
اكمل سرد القصه واعطاء المعلومات لحتى
للمتابعين الكرام لحتى هن يقدروا كمان
يعني ياخذوا صوره اوسع واشمل عما نتحدث
عنه هون ونتابع الحديث
على ما يبدو فان هناك بضع شركات فقط وان
كانت عالميه تسيطر على معظم ان لم يكن كل
ما نستهلك من غذاء للعلم انا على فكره
بتحدث عن العالم اجمع مش بلد واحد او حتى
قاره واحده بل العالم منظمه وهي حركه
عالميه زي ما بتعرفوا او زي ما هي بتعرف
عن نفسها تكافح عدم المساواه وبتسعى
لانهاء الفقر والظلم حول العالم وهي تنطلق
في عملها من المجتمعات المحليه للعالميه
وبتعمل على الارض
لاحداث تغيير يدوم وبتركز على الالتزام
بعالميه حقوق الانسان المهم هاي المؤسسه
قامت بتصميم انفوجرافيك بتبين فيه كيف انه
عشر شركات فقط بتعطينا الوهم انه احنا
احرار في اختياراتنا لما بيتعلق الامر
بغذائنا بينما الحقيقه هي غير ذلك تماما
كل واحده من هاي الشركات العشره بين
جناحيها عدد مهول من العلامات التجاريه
وهو اللي بيشكل الوهم في وعينا انه احنا
حقا نختار ما نشتري وممن نشتري هاي
الشركات هي اولا نستله
وهاي الشركه تشير على موقعها انها بتملك
اكثر من 2000 علامه تجاريه يعني لو دخلتوا
على جوجل شو هي البرانس اللي بتملكها شركه
ناسله راح يطلع لكم عدد مهول من العلامات
التجاريه اختصارا للوقت راح اذكر بعضها في
القهوه مثلا نسكافيه نسبريسو ستاربكس اما
في المياه المعدنيه والغازيه فهناك
وسامبالغرينو واقوى بانا في الحلويات كيت
كات سمارتيز كواليتي ستريت ملك وفي
المشروبات المنزليه
اما في الايس كريم فعندها هاجنداز موفنبيك
ايضا بالنسبه لتعامل الاطفال هي تملك نيدو
وسريلا
والقائمه طبعا تطول لكن ما سبق كافي لحتى
يعطينا فكره عن حجم هاي الشركه الشركه
اخرى هي شركه كوكو كولا
هاي الشركه بتملك 200 علامه تجاريه شهيره
في عالم المشروبات فعدا عن الاسم الاشهر
وعليه ايضا اسم الشركه نفسها كوكاكولا هي
ايضا تملك ما يبدو لنا انه هن منافسيها
مثل سبرايت وفانتا وهذا في المشروبات
الغازيه لكن هل بتعرفوا انها كمان بتملك
سلسله مقاهي كوستا وعلامه داساني للمياه
المعدنيه وشويبس ومشروب الطاقه باور ريد
وبادي ارمر وكمان ضيفوا لما سبق علامات
شهيره من المشروبات الكحوليه ايضا
وطالما ذكرنا كوكاكولا فلابد انه نذكر
غريمتها او على الاقل هيك احنا نعتقد اللي
هي كولا فقط 23 علامه تجاريه تندرج تحتها
لكنها بتجني من هذه العلامات التجاريه
اكثر من مليار دولار سنويا من مبيعات
التجزئه فقط من علاماتها كويكر عصائر
تروبيكانا القهوه البارده اللي تباع في
ستاربكس وتذكروا طبعا اني سبق واشرت انه
من يملك ستاربكس اللي هي كوكاكولا المفروض
منافستها
ومشروب للرياضيين وشيبس دوريتوس وتشيتوس
وهناك ايضا اللي هي المياه المعدنيه شاي
ليبتون ايضا الشهير هو مملوك لبسي كولا
وصدقوا او لا كمان تندرج تحت علامات ارز
وحتى الحمص اه والله الحمص
عشان ما اطول عليكم بعتقد انه الصوره باتت
الان اوضح بكثير لكن لحتى اكملكم القائمه
فالشركات السبعه المكمله لهاي الشركات
اللي ذكرناها
هيلوكس ومارس وموندليز وشركه البريطانيه
المتحده للاغذيه وكمان المطاحن العامه
واذا انتابكم الفضول كل ما عليكم انكم
تعملوه هو انه تبحثوا على الانترنت عن
العلامات اللي بتملكها اي من هاي الشركات
لحتى تدركوا انهم في المحصله عباره عن
يمكن السوبر ماركت كله عوده لحديثنا استاذ
علي من الواضح بانه في يعني شركات معينه
لا تتعدى كونها يعني تعد على اصابع اليد
هي التي تسيطر نوعا ما على كل قراراتنا
الاستهلاكيه حتى لما نفكر انه احنا في عنا
نوع من انواع الاختيار ما بين هذا المنتج
او ذاك نكتشف او هذا ما وانا من خلال هاي
الحلقه والاعداد لالها لانه من يملك هذا
المنتج وذاك وذاك هم نفس الجهه الى اي مدى
فعلا يعني اذا لو رجعنا بالهرم الى راسه
سنجد راس واحده تتحكم بكل ذلك
لم يعد سرا الان على سبيل المثال
وهذا يتعمل يعني في اطار
يعني يمكن تسمينه كذا
مثلا الان يقولون التسوق الشبكي يعني في
راسه وفي تسلسل هرمي يعني كذا جاي مثل
الاخطبوط والسرطانات ومشابه ذلك وهذه
الشركات يعني سبحان الله احنا انا لما
اتكلم انه نظريه المؤامره فانا اتفهم
لماذا الغرب يحارب كما قال انا نشرت على
فكره فيديو من يومين يقول في مسؤول امريكي
يقول لن نسمح لاحد في العالم ان ينافسنا
فهم واضحين في هذه الحرب حرب معلنه حرب
معلنه ليست خفاءه على فكره اصبحت الان حرب
معلنه
كلها امريكية نوعا ما او في منها مساهمين
مش بالضروره الامريكان يعني لكن نفسها
غربي احتلالي يعني مثلا على سبيل المثال
شوفي كل انسان مثل ما تقولي كذا كل دوله
وكل ثقافه عاده يعني تعرف من مروث
الاخلاقي
يعني في في في قاعده جميله في علم القانون
يا راويه تقول ان العقوبه انتبه معي ان
العقوبه
بحجم انكار المجتمع للجرم
عقوبه في القانون بحجم انكار المجتمع
للجرم يمكن منطقي عشرين سنه هنا وتحصليها
ثلاثه شهور هنا مع وقف التنفيذ ليه
الانكار هنا غليظ والانكار هنا شبه معدوم
وعند استعداد انه يعني تقتل كل شيء وتحارب
كل شيء انت تعرفي انه احتلال العراق 2003
كان عشانها تشتغل شركه هاليبورتون تشتغل
فتشوف الامور الى يوميا يعني تدمير الدول
كامله في امريكا الوسطى كان بسبب شركات
موز امريكيه يعني هنا الفارق ما بين يعني
هل ممكن انه نقول بانه الاقتصاد او هذه
الشركات فعليا ممكن ان تحرك السياسه هل
تصل الامور لهذه الدرجه تحرك حكومات
ورؤساء باكملهم
وتحكمهم نوعا ما اذا انت بتقول بانه الحرب
حرب
العراق كانت علشان شركه شركه نفط
وغاز عشان تشتغل
نعم انا اجيب لك كلام الناس اللي هم اقروا
هذه الحرب وقادوها مش من راسي معلومات
فهمتي يعني بالفعل مساله انه يعني في في
دول في دول قامت وفيها مؤسسات
وفي شركات اقام الدول ومؤسسات
يعني دوله مثل امريكا اقامتها الشركه
واقامتها اللوبيات ليست هناك دوله في
امريكا هناك لوبيات لها جيوش ولها مؤسسات
هنا الفرق بينما الدول الاخرى كلها دول
قامت راس الهرمي موجود ثم مؤسسات وبالتالي
السياسه تقود الاقتصاد في امريكا الاقتصاد
يوجه السياسه ويوجه العسكريه ويوجه
الاجهزه الامنيه وهكذا
النفس الاكبر في امريكا وانتقلت منه
العدوى لبعض الدول ذات نفس الاستعماري
وتحديدا انجلترا حتى لا يشمل بريطانيا
كلها انجلترا وفرنسا الانسان عندهم نفس
النفس يعني اريد الدول وحكومات واغتيالات
وفي سبيل
وكانت من ابرز القوى الاستعماريه في
العالم كلها في الواجهه شركات اما في
الوادي على فكره الشركات اللي بتحركت هذه
هذه الدول ولم يصل احد يعني انت قلتي في
البدايه ما يمكن نفصل ما بين نظريه
المؤامره والسياسه حقيقه صح يعني انا لو
ارجع لك الى مثلا عام 1968 ايش اللي حصل
في فرنسا حركه طلابيه ضخمه جدا ما يسميها
بربيع براغ انتقل الى كل اوروبا تقريبا هم
ربطوها باغتيال جفاره في بوليفيا صح هذا
له دور والمد اليساري في اوروبا صحيح نفس
الشيء لكن كان ايضا مثل ربيع العبري اللي
صار عندنا انه فرصه لهذا الغطاء ان يندسم
من تحته ايضا برامج اخرى وكان من ضمن
البرامج المجتهدفه في فرنسا اسقاط يقول
كحكومه وطنيه
وتغول الصهيونيه لغايه اليوم فرنسا لا
تحكم نفسها
فبالتالي من سهل جدا توجيه ايضا هذه
الاشياء وتوجيه هذا المؤسسات لتصبح ادوات
يعني تصبح الدوله في النهايه ادوات
طيب شو بيكون الهدف يعني من لو اخذنا احنا
طبعا راح نفصل لسه رح نحكي عن شركات
متخصصه في منتجات مختلفه او ممكن يكون في
الها تاثير بطريقه اخرى لو حكينا عن
الشركات المتخصصه في السلع الاستهلاكيه
اللي بتاثر على حياتنا بشكل يومي شو هدفها
الربح فقط هذا هو هذا هو الربح طيب شو شو
حدود ايضا
يعني
كما يقال يعني لوين ممكن يوصلوا بالجشع شو
حدود الرغبه في تحقيق الارباح اذا كانوا
اصلا يحكموا العالم من خلال هذه الشركات
الاخلاق عندما
لابد ان يكون في اطار معين بهذا الشيء
اطير بهذا الشيء ايضا
الاقتصادره الاخلاق ماذا يصبح يصبح بشاعه
ويصبح استغلال وعبوديه طبعا بكل التفاصيل
هؤلاء الناس انتقلوا على مراحل على فكره
انتقلوا من والى يعني كانوا على قدر من
الانسانيه وكان على قدر كذا صحيح عندما
كان الاقتصاد بايدي التجار انتبهي هذا
حاله مهمه جدا عندما كان الاقتصاد بعيد
التجار كان عندهم قيم التجاره وكان عندهم
المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه عاليه وكان عندهم
قيم الموروث الاخلاقي وما شابه ذلك
نحن نعاني في السنوات الاخيره او في
العقود الاخيره من ثقافه الاثرياء
ثقافه الثراء تختلف كليا عن ثقافه التجاره
الثري هذا في الغالب العام نام في الليل
الصباح قالوا هاتف ايا كان هذا الهاتف
مبروك جالك ولد
الولد هذا قد يكون مليار قد يكون 100
مليون قد يكون قد يكون بورصه ضربت معه
اسهم ايا كان فبالتالي هذا في الغالب
الاعم يعمل بنفسيه يعني الحصاله او جهنم
هل من مزيد
انا والله يا شيخ رحمه الله عليه عندي
صديق ملياردير
يقول لي اوعى تصدق يا ابو حسين اللي يكذب
عليك ويقول لك انا باخذ مليون ريال عماني
واتوقف يكذب
طبعا هو يتكلم من تجربته
او انسان يقول لك بس خلاص بوصلها الى عشره
مليون يكذب دائما في رغبه للمزيد عند
الانسان
تشتغل معه نظريه على البشريه
وبعدين المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه شبه معدومه
والغايه تبرر الوسيله المكيليه تشتغل
فهمتي هنا تعتمد فلسفه الانسان يا راضيه
ماذا يعني لك المال هل هو سيل ام غايه من
الاختلاف مع هذه هذا سؤال فلسفي ممكن ممكن
تكون وسيله لغايه ما احقق قدر كافي من
الثراء وبعد هيك بتصير غايه
ولكن في يعني ايضا ممكن المال تجمعه لكن
يكون عندك بس هي تحقيق يعني اشياء كثيره
واسعاد الاخرين واسعاد نفسك
فيعيشون حياه الفقراء ويحاسبون حساب
الاغنياء يعني
ولا هو من حساب يوم القيامه فبالتالي هذا
المؤسسات لا يمكن ان نفصلها انت تعرفي في
عشرات المنتجات اللي انا اعرفها يمكن مئات
المنتجات اللي يعرفوها غيري غير مصرح بها
في الاسواق المحليه الامريكيه والاوروبيه
مكتوب عليها الاستهلاك خارج او الاستعمال
خارج هذا البلد وهم حدوتهم ماذا حجتهم
يقول لك والله هذه لا تخضع للمواصفات اذا
ابحث عن اسواق ما في مواصفات او مواصفات
متدنيه فبالتالي يظهرون يعني اشياء لا
تتخيلينها في الاسواق الاخرى والعين
الموجود نتيجه غياب المواصفات فاهمه او
غياب المختبرات على سبيل المثال
وبعدين انت يعني انتقلي الى نقطه ثانيه في
شيء اخطر من هذا كله يا راضيه وهو ما يسمى
بالمخابرات الاقتصاديه انت اكيد لاحظتي
مثلي ومثل غيري انه والله ما احد مش عارف
ايش في يقول ان الشوكولاته مفيده للقلب
يجيك والله ما عاد في يقول لك ان
الشوكولاته ضاره يجيك مش عربي
الصباح يقول لك القهوه لا تزيدنا هذه كلها
حروب
اقتصاديه استخباراتيه
يعني هذه الشركات العملاقه على سبيل
المثال اخبرك انت مش قبل فتره اكيد تابعتي
اخبار ان شركه
شو اسمها ترامبول شيكس
تصبري بفعل انه شركه سامسونج عندها جهاز
استخبارات اقتصادي خطير سحبت قبل الغيار
بشهر
فكانت تكون الشركه الوحيده اللي ما خسرت
اي شيء من توماسكو لانه راسلت الامور
وبتتحرى لها عن طريق الاذرع الاستخباراتيه
طيب في المقابل الاستخبارات
المنافسين في مشاريع وهميه انا عندي ملابس
خطير راويه عنده راس مال وعنده نفس تفكيري
انا القبيل ليش ما مهم انه يمكن توجه هذا
راس المال الى مصنع ملابس مثلا في مكان
وانا اعرف انه نسبه الريسك عالي جدا
فبالتالي اغرقها هناك حتى اتفرغ انا
الجبهه هنا
كثير مشروعات وهميه
بانه هاي المنافسه بتكون على المستوى
المنخفض لانه لو مره اخرى لو رجعنا لراس
الهرم
بنلاحظ بانه حتى هاي الشركات
تبدو وكانها متنافسه هي فعليا مملوكه لنفس
الاصل لنفس لنفس الشخص او الاشخاص او
مجموعه الاشخاص او شركه معينه هولدن شركه
قابضه هي التي تملك كل هذه الشركات التي
تتنافس وبشكل شديد جدا مع بعضها البعض على
مستوى القاعده حتى في بعض يعني الشركات
المتنافسه تملك حصص في بعضها البعض يعني
في الشركه التي تنافسها الموضوع معقد جدا
فبالتالي يعني
هم تقريبا من 30 سنه تقريبا بداوا على خجل
ثم انتفعوا اصبحوا راس المهد هذا بشع اصبح
يبحث عن اماكن ارخص في العالم للاستثمار
فنقلوا التقنيه بلا شعوب
اللي كانت يعني هي مثل ما تقول لي كذا
مستحوذه عن الطاقه في العالم اصبحت
اسرارها في العالم كله الشركات العابره
للقارات لم تعد لها هويه انتبهي صعب جدا
السيطره عليها اصبح هكذا صعب جدا انك انت
تسيطر عليها قرارها اصبح براس مالها لم
يعد قرارها لمرجعها الاصل اصبح لها اسم
هنا واسم هنا واسم هنا وهكذا
بالتالي فقد الغرب شيء اسمه الرياده والسر
لم يعد هناك سر الان اغلب الشركات بتصنع
في الصين وفي المكسيك وفي تركيا وفي
نيجيريا وبكره في مصر واندونيسيا والمغرب
وكذا اذا هم فقدوا السر وعندما فقدوا السر
اصبح من امكان جدا ان تقلد هذه البضائع
وبالتالي كسدت بضاعتهم يبحثون عن راس
المال العاري باي شكل كان وعن طريق هذا
الكسب العالي هذا افتعلوا لعلمك حتى
الازمات الازمات التي تحدث الان في اغلب
البلدان ركزي عليها هي البلدان المصدره
للعماله حتى يفقدونهم الامان وبالتالي
هاجروا الملايين انت لاحظي في اوروبا الان
المعسكرات اللاجئين ما تسمى معسكرات
اللاجئين يا راويه وبعدين ينتقوا منها
رابيه لانه عندها ماجستير وعلي لان عنده
بكالوريوس وكذا وبقيه العمال يرحلون الى
دول جوار يقول لك
خلينا نقول او العمل المتخصصه المفيده
بابخس الاثمان او بثمن ارخص مما قد يجدوه
من المواطنين لديهم
الان يعني في حرج عظيم البشعه هذه في حرجة
عظيمه اولا بالنسبه للكسب لم يعد هناك
اسرار اصبحوا هم عباره عن كتاب مفتوح
الامر الثاني نتيجه
الشيخوخه التي تدب في هذا المجتمعات فهم
مجبرين ومكرهين الى ادخال ثقافات واديان
واعراف اخرى من كان يتوقع يوم من الايام
انه
بريطانيا هندي لا يمكن هم اساسا كانوا
الطبقه يعني الرثه الطبقه المسحوقه في
بريطانيا نفسها رغم انه بريطانيا نهبت من
او انجلترا بالاحرة ذهبت من الهند اثنين
واربعين تريليون
استاذ علي في في موضوع الشركات التي تحكم
او تملك العالم خلينا نقول بانه لما
الواحد بيطلع على الموضوع يعني بحس بانه
طيب هي بتحاول انها تاثر على اختياراتنا
بماذا نستهلك في النهايه بيرجع الموضوع
لالنا لانه ممكن نقرر انه ما نستهلك اي من
هذه المنتجات مع انه هي تقريبا يعني جل ما
موجود في الاسواق وفي السوبر ماركت ولكن
لما نعرف انه مثلا شركه مثل بلاك روك اللي
تندرج تحتيها شركات مهوله هلا طبعا راح
اشرحها بشكل مفصل اكثر لاعزائي المتابعين
شركه مثل هاي هي الشركه الوحيده اللي الها
عندها عقد
رسمي
والوحيده المخوله بانها
تقوم باقراض النظام البنكي الامريكي يعني
البنك المركزي الامريكي
بحس الواحد بانه الموضوع يمكن اعمق واكبر
من ذلك بكثير مثل هاي الشركات الاستهلاكيه
كيف تتحكم بحياتنا بعيدا عن الاختيارات
فيما يتعلق بماذا نستهلك هي الخطوره
اختراق مش قصه استهلاك احنا فينا نعوض
الشيء بالشيء ممكن الى حد ما يعني على
سبيل المثال وحسب ثقافته وقناعه الانسان
المشكله اللي الناس مش منتبهين لها
يعني هي تبعات هذا الاستهلاك يا اختي
راويه انت لما تاكل مثلي تلبس مثلي وتسكن
مثلي تفكر مثلي
يعني هذه نوع من انواع طمس الهويه الشخصيه
والخصوصيه
الاقليميه او المحليه لاي مكان الان انا
استغرب من الناس اللي يقول لك يا اخي
انتوا العرب بتضيعوا من وقتكم ساعات في
الطبخ والبهارات والسلطات والمقبلات
والفتوش وكذا وكذا يا اخي في امريكا يقول
لك تيت تيت على طول ينزل لك يا اخي اذا
كان هذا الناس ما عندهم ثقافه
واذا كانت الناس ما عندهم قيم الضمه ولا
تقاليد وش دخلني فيهم انا كيف تريدني ان
انا اقتدي بالامريكي ولا الاوروبي وكانهم
الملاذ الطبيعي والاخير للبشريه يا راويه
جزء من العولمه نوعا ما يعني اوكي لا لا
حاجه ثانيه فهمتيني يعني انا مره اقول لك
يعني خليني احب عبر اكون شرعي كذا في بعض
الاجابات مره كنا على طاوله كذا وكان عندي
صديق رحمه الله عليه
اساس انه نتغدى وعندنا ضيوف فجالس يلعب
بالسكينه وكذا قال يا اخي اكيد هذا السكين
هذا اخترعه العرب عشان يطعنون بعضهم بعض
يمزح
كلنا بالنسبه والتناسب وكذا قلت له يا
شيخنا بخبرك حاجه ايهما اهم لحياه الانسان
ركز السكين امن الكمبيوتر على طول منطقيا
الاجازه النمطيه لان جواب النمط الجاهز
يقول لك الكمبيوتر هنا بالسكين لما اخترع
يا راويه عمل الانقلاب في حياه البشر
اختراع السكين نفسه
فنهايه المطاف كل ما اتى به الغرب لا
يساوي سكين نهايه المطاف بمعنى انه ما اتى
به الغرب هو منافع انسانيه ليست هويه يعني
هذه المنا
الهويه اذا المساله هذه حرب حضاريه ولا
تكون حرب وجود اذا انا استطيع ان اعيش
بدون كمبيوتر وبدون نستله وبدون فورد
وبدون وبدون استطيع ان اعيش دبي لكن هو لا
يستطيع هذا الاوروبي والغربي لا يستطيع ان
يعيش بلا سكين ولا ادوات طبخ طينيه ولا
نظام روي ولا ما يستطيع هم لم ياتوا بشيء
بس في النهايه برضه ما احنا كمان يعني
نتطلع الى الامام مش للوراء يعني بانه
نستطيع ان نعيش من دون كل هذه الامور ولكن
شو كيف راح تكون جوده حياتنا بالزمن اللي
احنا عايشين فيه بدون كمبيوتر اكيد طبعا
الاكل اهم لانه هذا بياثر على وجودنا من
عدمه اصلا يعني وكل الادوات المرتبطه
بالسرفايفل خلينا نقول اللي هي البقاء على
قيد الحياه مهمه جدا
ولكن بالزمن اللي احنا عايشين فيه في صار
في مقومات مختلفه للحياه او ادوات مختلفه
للحياه انا حبيتني اركز على الحقيقه موضوع
اخر او جانب اخر من من هذا الحديث عن
نظريه المؤامره او من يملك العالم اذا
بتسمح لي خليني اتابع
اخبار المتابعين عن تفاصيل هذه القصه
ومتابع الحديث طيب لو نظرنا لصناعه الميك
اب او كما نسميها نحن العرب بالمكياج هاي
الصناعه مسيطر عليها من سبع شركات فقط
بينهم بيملكوا 182 علامه تجاريه تحديدا
هاي الشركات هي لوريال
اللي ذكرت ذكرتها سابقا ضمن شركات الاغذيه
كمان
اللي هي ايضا بتعمل مواد استهلاكيه
بالدرجه الاولى وجونسون جونسون اللي كمان
متخصصه بالمعدات الطبيه والسلع
الاستهلاكيه مره اخرى لو تملككم الفضول
ابحثوا عن العلامات التجاريه اللي بتملكها
كل من هاي الشركات لكن للاسف مده الحلقه
مش رح تسعفني للقيام بشرحها كلها لكن من
السهل بمكان انه نتخيل كيف انه ما تعلن
عنه هذه الشركات السبع سنويا هو بالفعل
وبطريقه مباشره وغير مباشره هو اللي بحدد
لنساء العالم اجمع كل سنه او حتى كل فصل
من السنه ما هو جميل وما هو رائج وما هو
مقبول وما هو غير ذلك اذا الامر صار اشبه
بغسيل ادمغه
بالنسبه لصناعه الالبسه هي لديها عشره
كبار بينهم بيملكوا ما يقرب من 50% من
السوق العالمي بحسب تقرير ستانلي صدر عام
ومن ليس ضمن هؤلاء العشره مهما كبر حجمه
مش راح تزيد حصته العالميه عن اثنين في
الميه فقط هاي الشركات هي نايكي
شانيل اديداس
اما بالنسبه للاعلام العالمي فطبعا حدث
ولا حرج هذا الاعلام اللي غالبه بيتبع ما
تصدره الولايات المتحده بكلمات اخرى
فالامريكان هم من يصنعون الترند في شتى
مجالات الاعلام في هذا الحقل سهلت الشركات
المالكه الامر فجعلت خمسه منها فقط تدير
الاعلام الامريكي وبالمحصله او الطبيعيه
الاعلام
وقنواتها اللي بتجني سنويا 62 ونص مليار
دولار بعد اشهر قنواتها ام اس ام بي سي
وبعدين عنا شركه تايم اللي بتجني 30 مليار
سنويا اللي من ضمن شركاتها او محطاتها اتش
بي او
اذرعها الانتاجيه خلينا نقول ولدينا ايضا
42 مليار سنويا اللي تحتها بيندرج مارفل
وبيكسار
مليار سنويا اللي تحتها
نيكلوديوند ونيوز اللي بتجني 34 مليار
اللي تحتها فوكس وتايمز
لو حصرنا انتاجهم معا فمش راح اكون مبالغه
لو قلت لكم انه ما في شي لا بنسمعه او
منشاهدو او حتى بنقراه احنا او اي فرد من
افراد اسرتنا ياتي من خارج هاي الشركات
يعني هي قادره على تشكيل وتوجيه واعي
العالم باسره كما تريد وهي قادره على
القاء الضوء على ما يخدم انجندتها واهمال
ما يخالف هاي الاجنده ايا كان حجمه واهميه
الحدث الامر بيبدا بالصغار طبعا عبر افلام
الكرتون وينتهي بنا نحن الكبار بنشرات
الاخبار والمجلات والجرائد سواء كانت
ورقيه ام الكترونيه والمحتوى الترفيهي
اللي احنا بنستهلكه على منصات مختلفه مثل
نتفليكس وغيره
عوده الى استاذ علي
في موضوع الشركات الاعلاميه الحقيقه انا
يعني وجدت خطوره في هذا الموضوع او هذا
الجانب لسه اكثر بكثير من الجانب
الاستهلاكي لانه هون عم نحكي عن رسائل بتم
توصيلها بيكون في الها اهداف معينه ممكن
تشكل نوع من انواع غسيل الدماغ وتغير
ثقافات تغير نمط تفكير وتغير سياسات وتغير
حياه شعوب لو مثلا اخذنا طبعا بالامثله
اللي انا ذكرتها بحيث انه يعني لو فكرنا
بانه او حطينا بعين بعين الاعتبار بانه
مالك هذه الشركات الاعلاميه المختلفه اللي
هون عم نحكي عن محطات اخبار بنحكي عن
شركات انتاج ونحكي عن هوليود عن كل هذه
الشركات اللي بتصنعه النتفليكس كلها اللي
بتصنع المحتوى اللي احنا بنستهلكه بغض
النظر عن نوعه لما يكون مالكها واحد
معناته توحيد الرساله اشي سهل جدا فاذا
ارادوا انهم يطبعوا او
يعني
يبلعونا اي نوع من انواع الرسائل ما راح
يكون هذا الشيء صعب لانه كل اذرع هاي
الماكينه بتشتغل في نفس الوقت خلينا نحكي
اكثر عن هذا الجانب اللي بعتقد بانه خطير
جدا
اعلاميه لو انا اعطيك الان ارسل لك الان
في حسابك عشره مليون دولار شو راح تعملي
اجاوب عنك انا اطمح اني اعمل قناه فضائيه
مثلا ليش
منطقي لو قلت له طيب
[موسيقى]
مثلا وقيسي عليها ما تشائين هؤلاء الناس
من يمتلك المال يمتلك الخيال فهمتني يعني
المال هو الوقود الاول والاخير بهذا الشيء
القصه مش فيهم هم القصه في ماذا اعددت انت
لكبح جماع هؤلاء الناس في التاثير ماذا
عدد يعني انا اخبرك بحاجه 86 لي راويه
يخبرني صديق قال حضرنا ندوه في تونس
طيب لمواجهه الغزو الفضائيه القادم شوفي
86 ايام ما كنت في الجزائر
العمانيه في الجزائر
فتصور يقول كان معنا الماني الماني اعطانا
تجربته في مقاومه الغزو الثقافي الاعلامي
بالنسبه للالمان
فعندهم تجربه قالوا رصدنا ان السكان
المناطق المحاديه لسويسرا لا يتابعون
الالماني وبالذات التلفزيون
عملنا حصر واستبيانات فتبين لنا بانه جوده
البث السويسري ارقب كثير من جوده البث
الالماني يستهويهم
فلما رفعنا الى الاداره حسنوا كثيرا وبدو
يتابعوا فوجدوهم تلقائيا الغالبيه العظمى
عند رفيق العلم الالماني بعد تحسين
احنا نتكلم عن هذه النوعيه تعرفي من ضمن
التوصيات على فكره قالوا العرب محصنين من
غزوه الثقافي الاعلامي تعرفي ليش نسبه
نسبه الجهل كبيره اولا
نافعه معنا
ونسبه اللغويات ايضا يعني كبيره ليش هم
الان لجوا الى التعريب القنوات الفضائيه
الرساله لاختراق المجتمع ما كانوا هكذا
كان
بالانجليزي وسكين نيوز بالانجليزي مين راح
النخبه
يعني انا شيء بشيء يذكر تعرفي من ضمن
الاتفاقيه الثقافيه
قال لك تبادل الكتب والمعلومات وباللغتين
وجدوا انه في مصر لا يقرا العبريه الا
المخابرات
فانما فيما يسمى باسرائيل 80% يقرون
العربي فالتكافؤ النديه زارت مصر
فهذا اقول لك من ضمن الاشياء الموجوده
بالفعل يعني حتى اللي انت ذكرتيهم انه من
يملك هذا الامبراطوري في نهايه المطاف شخص
بينما هذا الشخص او شركه جهه جهه يعني جهه
معينه واحده
والمشكله ان ايضا المالكه الحقيقي في الظل
على فكره اه طبعا يعني هذا مجرد واجه على
سبيل المثال هؤلاء الناس يعملون يجب انه
نحلل المجتمع الامريكي يتكون من من على
سبيل المثال من ماذا تكبرت امريكا تكابره
امريكا
هو نفسه اذا كان هناك نظريه مؤامره فهم
ضحيه له ايضا مش بس بقيه العالم
انه احنا اساسا يعني انا مش انا كيف انت
مش انت
نهايه المطاف هم داخلين في زبونيه سياسيه
خطيره جدا
يعني
تعرضت في ايام كورونا
في ناس
زين الكشف في امريكا يكلف 3000 دولار صوري
عشان اكشف عنك من عنده 3000 دولار وبعدين
يغطيك التامين الصحي شو الحدث
ماتت الملايين
كل دوله تعاني من بعض المشاكل يعني
والولايات المتحده ليست استثناء نهائيا
على مستوى الحكومه على مستوى الشعب
كما كانت نقدر نقول هيك يعني
وفي المقابل 37 مليون هملس
هذا قبل كورونا 37 مليون مشردين
53 مليون 53 مليون امريكي يا يتحدث اللغه
الانجليزيه معقوله
قنواتهم كلها لاتين واسبانيه وما شابه
البرتغاليه
طيب على كل حال يعني هو حتى كورونا اصلا
كان موضع
اهتمام المؤمنين او المؤمنين بنظريات
المؤامره خصوصا لما يعني انا بعد ما عملت
بحث وحاولت اني اربط بعض الخيوط في انه
شركات الادويه ما هي مملوكه ربما البعض
منها لنفس المنظومه
وربما كلها
يعني قد يكون لها اجنده معينه لا احد يعلم
اذا كان او منقدرش نجزم هاي هي مشكلت
نظريه المؤامره انها واضحه وليست واضحه
موجوده ولكن صعب الايمان فيها او يعني على
حسب اختيار الشخص من اي منظور يريد ان
ينظر ان يرى الدلائل او ان لا يراها لانها
قد تكون دلائل او او غير ذلك ولكن فيما
يتعلق بالشركات الاعلاميه انا الحقيقه كنت
حابه يعني احكي على مثال معين اللي الضجه
التي قامت على موضوع تطبيع المثليه
الجنسيه في المدارس وحتى في افلام الكرتون
واللي هي نوعا ما هذا بالنسبه للاطفال
يعني جاءت على عده مستويات حتى بالنسبه
لكبار السن للبالغين فبتلاقيها موجوده
بكتير من المحتوى اللي موجود على نتفليكس
اللي بيستهلكوه الاهل وبعدين الاطفال لما
بيتفرجوا على افلام كرتون برضو الموضوع
حاضر ونوعا ما مطبع هل بيكون في اتفاق على
اجنده معينه على رساله معينه ومن من يقرر
على اي اساس انه احنا بدنا نطبع بهذا
الموضوع بدنا تبش هاي المسج او هاي
الرساله
هذا عصابه المليار الذهبي في العالم هي
اللي شغاله اسقطت حكومات سكيتي وتم اغتيال
الناس على فكره حتى في الغرب يعني ما
نستغني منها يعني
صدام حسين واليسار وكذا وكذا وبتيل وبعد
ما منعت هددت النمسا بالخروج من الاتحاد
الاوروبي ما لم تعد الانتخابات
روبر كوك وزير خارجيه بريطانيا كيف مات
وين راح المخلوق هذا لما قال انه محكمه
العدل الدوليه لم تقام
فكثير من الناس وكثير من الضمائر الحيه
الذين تمت تمت ابادتهم سكيتي وتم اختراقهم
وتنصيب فلان وعلان هم شغالين شغالين
بطريقه منظمه وعندهم نفس طويل وعندهم
تجربه تراكميه ومش مستعجلين وبالتالي
تستغربي انت يعني كيف كان يا راويه في
الستينات يرجع الى الفيديوهات في الستيرات
تسعه وستين وين بلدون اللاعبات والفستان
الطويل
فستان طويل والله كانها دميه بتتحرك باربي
مغطيه اليدين وبتلعب عادي ما في اشكال كيف
تطورت الامور وانا شفت فيديو عن فتره قبل
فتره
يتكلموا في الستينات انه ربما تصبح
الازياء هكذا احنا مستحيل نلبسهم ضروري في
الستينات هذا الكلام لو صار له فستان كذا
مستحيل ما بالك بالاشي مستحيل يعني خصوصا
فيما يتعلق بالازياء يجب ان تدرس هذه
التحولات لماذا حصلت هل هي حاجه ام في جزء
من نظريه المؤامره يتحدث عن انه تحرير
المراه واعطاء المراه حقوقها وحتى الحقوق
المدنيه في الغرب حق
الانتخاب الحقوق فيما يتعلق بالحقوق
الشخصيه او في قانون الاحوال الشخصيه
والمدنيه كلها نابعه او نظريه المؤامره في
هذا الاطار بتحكي بانه الهدف منها كلها
اخراج المراه من بيتها
وبالتالي يعني عشان تدفع ضرائب بدل ما
كانوا نص الشعب بدفع ضرائب اللي هن الرجال
فقط خلينا خلي كل الشعب يدفع ضرائب يعني
اعتقد انه هاي نظريه مؤامره كتير ناس
بيعرفوها بيعرفوا او سامعين فيها ولكن لا
احد يعلم لانه في النهايه النتيجه كانت
نوعا ما جيده تحرير المراه او على الاقل
تمكين المراه اعطائها حقوقها اعطائها
مكانه توازي مكان الرجل
اعطائها قيمه او يعني الاعتراف بقيمتها
التي تضاهي قيمه الرجل في هذا في اي مجتمع
فالنتيجه كانت ايجابيه وان حتى وان صحت
نظريه المؤامره لخلفها بانه الهدف كان غير
شريف ابدا
انه طالما الانبهار موجود بالغرب في ناس
بالملايين يعتقدوا ان النموذج الغربي
والمناذل الاخير الكارثه وبالتالي يهرولون
هذه العقليه ما زالت سائده يعتقد انه يعني
عند صناع القرار والسياسه موجوده شوف
الغرب وشوف الغرب وشوفوا الغربة عجيبه
هؤلاء الناس لا يؤمنون ان الله خلق هذه
البشريه زين لتعارفوا
لما يقول لك يا ايها الناس انك خلقناكم من
ذكر وانثى وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائل لتعارفوا
لا تذوبوا ولا تهيمنوا ولا ولا
يقول لك انك خلقنا هذا الفعل اللازم
الاصيل خلقنا ثم انطنا المسؤوليه وجعلناكم
شعوبا وقبائل شوفي الخلق والجعل شيء اخر
لا لا عرب ومسلمين نعرف الثقافات الشرقيه
يعرفوا ان هذا التباين موجود وساره موجود
وسياره الله الارض من عليها وما عليها
والبشر مختلفون في كل شيء ولا حدا يختلف
على اهميه هذا التنوع يريد يخلق منه قالب
واحد بالاكراه
تاكل مثلي انت اعتقد على الاقل مجتمعاتنا
يعني ما زالت محافظه على هويتها وعلى
كيانها حتى لو ان يعني
انصهرنا نوعا ما بالحياه العصريه ولكن ما
زال لنا خصوصيتنا الجميله اللي مجتمعنا
الشرقي والعربي والاسلامي ما زلنا محتفظين
يعني بمقوماته يعني يبقى هذا الاحتفاظ
وكذلك لا يسعني هون الا اني اشاركهم دهشتي
من تركيبه نظام العالم المالي القائم على
البنوك فكبر هاي المؤسسات بتتوزع فقط على
ست دول كلها بتملك مجتمعه ما يقرب من
25.1 تريليون دولار بحسب موقع منظمه
انترناشو بزنس كايد هذا المبلغ صدقه او لا
تصدقوا هو كفيل باعطاء كل انسان يتنفس على
هذا الكوكب برمته مبلغ 3500 دولار وطبعا
احنا عارفين انه التعداد السكاني للعالم
وصل وسجل في 2022 8 مليار شخص لكن
من هي هذه البنوك واين تقع بنك اي سي بي
سي الصين بنك
المملكه المتحده دويتش بنك المانيا بي ان
بي فرنسا كريدت اجريكول فرنسا
ميتسوبيشي يو اف جي اليابان
بريطانيا جيبي مورجان الولايات المتحده
وبنك الانشاءات الصيني في الصين
في اليابان
صراحه البحث محاوله الربط ما بين القطاعات
المختلفه ومن يملك ماذا او من يملك حصه في
شركات اخرى كفيله باعطاء اي شخص بحاول
صداع بصراحه ممكن يدوم اثره للابد لذلك
اختصارا للوقت راح اشارككم تقرير وجدته
على موقع اسمه جلوبال
في
29/7/2021 اي انه حديث نسبيا بعنوان من
يملك العالم في المختصر بيشرح المقال كيف
انه اكبر بنوك امريكا كلها مملوكه في
النهايه لاربع شركات فقط حاولوا فقط
التركيز معي بهاي الاسماء
هؤلاء الاربعه هم الملكين للنسبه الاعلى
في البنوك الامريكيه التاليه بانكو ميريكا
جايبين
بنك
ستانلي وبانك
بقي انه نتحدث عن الشق الاقتصادي من هذا
الموضوع او الشق المالي لانه حتى هاي
الهيمنه طبعا تتغلغل كمان في القطاع
البنوك بحيث انه برضه كل البنوك نوعا ما
في العالم على ما يبدو اذا بترجع لراس
الهرم راس الهرم قد يكون واحد ايضا الهدف
من كل ذلك هل هي يعني السيطره السياسيه من
خلال اغراق دول وشركات
الافراد بالديون طبيعي انه هذا ايضا
البنوك اصبحت عباره عن حبال شد الناس
والدول الى الى بيت الطاعه معروف بقصه
فانت تعرفي ايش قلت لك انا بدايه الحديث
قلت لك دائما القاعده القانونيه ان
العقوبه بحجم انكار المجتمع للجرم طيب هذا
معناته ايش معناته انه العلم والتجربه ما
لم توطن ستبقى الحبل السري انت مع الاخر
التوطين ضروري يعني البنوك الان لما نشوف
البنوك في الوطن العربي على سبيل المثال
اي انسان تساله هل عمل البنكي هذا مدى
نصيب من العروبه واسلامك واخلاقك ما في
نسبه وتناسب اصلا
ماذا وطنت في هذا المنظومه بينما لما
يجيني شخص مثل محمد يونس في بنغلاديش
ويعمل
بنك الريف ويخرج خلال سنوات قليله 30
مليون بنغالي من خط الفقر تحت الى
الاكتفاء
الاقتصاد المنشود الاقتصاد الانساني يعني
حتى حتى ما يسمى الان بالاقتصاد الاسلامي
راويه ما هو الاقتصاد الاسلامي يسمون في
الغ
ربه
الخالي من الجشع الخالي من الاستغلال
والخالي من المبالغه في الارباح
الفائده المركبه
فيسمون يعني الاقتصاد القيمي على مره كنت
في ندوه وكذا بيتكلم عن صقر الاسلاميه
فبعد ما خلص الاخ المحاضر اسمعني انا ناو
من اساس انه في اقتصادي اسلامي يعني ما في
ايه تعلمك كيف تفتح حساب ولا في حديث
يعلمك كيف تاخذ قرض اصلا فقلت له المساله
في نهايه المطاف قياميه قال لي طيب هم
استاذ علي بيسموه كذا اصلا جابر المصطلح
بالانجليزي قال اقصاد الدعوه الى الاقتصاد
الاسلامي اي الاقتصاد الاخلاقي والغربي
يحارب اي منظمه تقرر بكره ولا بنك يقرر
انه ياخذ هذا المنظومه ستحاصر تحت البند
السابع
عندهم البند السابع الان القطط القطط
الروسيه منعت القطط الروسيه منعت من دخول
اوروبا تحت البند السابع اوروبا يعني
روسيا منعت من اي مشاركه في اي رياضه شوف
الامور شوفي ادواتهم
ازمته اوكرانيا كشفت اشياء اخطر بكثير مما
كنا نتوقعه وما كنا نعرفه
الحقيقه لا يملئ الحديث معك استاذ علي
للاسف هذا ما يسعفنا الوقت انه نناقشه
فاشكرك جزيل الشكر على وجودك معنا في كلام
منطقي واكيد راح يكون للحديث بقيه في
حلقات قادمه شكرا جزيلا واتمنى ان شاء
الله ان نتواصل على خير باذن الله تعالى
المخيف حقا انه الامر يصبح كانه بلاك هول
او ثقب اسود او مثلث برمودا فكلما توقلت
في بحثك ستصعق كيف ان الاسماء والملاك
تتقاطع لاعطيكم فكره هاي الشركات الاربعه
بتملك حصص في الشركات التاليه اللي
بنعرفها جميعا وهي حاضره في حياتنا
الاستهلاكيه يوميا او على الاقل بنسمع
اسمها باستمرار وهذا على سبيل المثال على
فكره وليس الحصر
وهذا غيض من فيض للعلم لانه القائمه تبدو
لي وكانها بلا نهايه اذا حقيقه صديقنا
اللي ذكرنا باول الحلقه وحتى لو ما كان
عارف كل التفاصيل ولكن ممكن انه يكون فعلا
على حق بصراحه بقسم لكم انه انا شعرت في
مرحله ما من بحثي انه من الممكن انه ينتهي
عمري وما راح تنتهي عمليه البحث والربط
هاي اذا هل هذه الشركات الاربع هي حقا من
يملك العالم صدقوني اني تمنيت لو انه
الامر ممكن يكون بهاي السهوله لحتى اتمكن
من انهاء بحثي وحلقتي لكن الجواب هو لا مش
هن هدول الشركات الاربعه قبل ما انهي يمكن
استطيع ان اقول انه والله اعلم انه هم فقط
شركتين اثنتين لا ثالث لهما بسيطر وبطريقه
بيعجز اي منا عن تصورها على كافه مفاصل
الحياه او على الاقل هم من وراء قراراتنا
في اي اتجاه نمضي سواء بما كلنا بمشربنا
او لباسنا او اين نسكن او كيف نصرف حتى
اموالنا الماليه وكيف نشكل ونبني قناعاتنا
ونتخذ قراراتنا ولانه هاي الحلقه بصراحه
بدات تشبه احداث الافلام
ظهرلي وانا عم بعمل البحث المطلوب لهذه
الحلقه وفي نتائج هذا البحث
ظهر لي تقرير لموقع يسمى زورو ويب حاولت
اني ابحث عن نوعيه يعني هذا الموقع
فوجدتني اغرق في دوامه اكبر لسه لكن وبعد
عناء وجدت احدى الصفحات اللي بتقدم خدمات
الدليل التجاري واسمها زوم انفو واللي
لديها شرح بسيط عن زورا او موقع زورا
المهم هي شركه لربحيه مقرها الولايات
المتحده بتوظف ما بين 11 لعشرين شخص هذا
كل ما وجدته عن هذا الموقع لكن عوده الى
تقرير زورو ويب اشار هذا التقرير واشار
كاتبه تحديدا جوزيف ماركولا الى انه
الشركتين اللتان تملكان العالم هم بلاك
روك وفانكورد خليني اعطيكم بعد مقتطفات
هذا التقرير بيقول بلاك روك وفانكورد
يملكون حصص كبيره في شركات مفصليه فان
قواعد تملك حصه كبيره في بلاك روك وبلاك
روك هي الشركه الخاصه الوحيده التي تملك
عقد تجاري واهلال لاقراض نظام البنك
المركزي الامريكي لد تسميتها من قبل شركه
بلومبرج
بالفرع الرابع للحكومه تخيلوا بيقول
ماكولا واللي يشير لفيديو معين موجود على
اليوتيوب ويشكو من المحاولات المتتاليه
لمحو وطمصه بيقول انظروا لقائمه الشركات
التاليه لحتى تعرفوا مدى تاثيراتين
الشركتين على حياتكم اليوميه
تملك حصص اكثريه في كل من الشركات التاليه
ركزوا معي جوجل يوتيوب فيسبوك تويتر
انستجرام امازون علي بابا
كوكاكولا مايكروسوفت افو نتفليكس
وبنظره سريعه راح ندرك مدى كبر هاي الشبكه
من الشركات وتوغلها في حياتنا جميعا بغض
النظر اين نعيش في هذا العالم هاي الشركات
بتتوزع ما بين منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
الشركات تسوق الكتروني صناعه اغذيه
تكنولوجيا صناعه دوائيه ترفيه اتصالات
طيران معدات طبيه سيارات واعلام
اذا
او طيب من يملك هاتين الشركتين
من المعروف انه بتملك الحصه الاكبر في
بلاك روك اذا من يملك فانغارت بيقول
مركولا من الواضح انها مملوكه من قبل عده
محافظ استثماريه واللي بدورها مملوكه
لمساهمين عدا عن هؤلاء المساهمين لا يسمح
لاحد من الخارج في الاستثمار فيها وهي
بالتالي شركه خاصه ما يعني انها غير
موجوده في الاسواق الماليه وكذلك هي غير
ملزمه بالافصاح عن اسماء مالكيها
متخيلين الصوره
وبقول من الواضح ان النخبه التي تمتلك لا
تحب الاضواء لكنهم لا يستطيعوا الاختباء
ممن يكون مستعدا للبحث والتنقيب فواحد في
المئه من البشر مجتمعين بيملكوا اكثر من
99% من باقي البشر
ويضيف ايضا بكلمات اخرى هاتين الشركتين
الاستثماريتين بانجورد وبلاك روك يحتكران
او تحتكران تقريبا كافه الصناعات في
العالم وهم مملوكتان من قبل اغنى العائلات
في العالم بعض هذه العائلات هي عائلات
ملكيه وهي غنيه غنى فاحش حتى قبل عصر
الثوره الصناعيه
في ختام حلقتنا ممكن يكون ماركولا مثل
صديقنا اللي ذكرناه في بدايه الحلقه لكن
الكثير من الحقائق اللي ذكرناها بحثت عنها
فوجدتها فعلا على الانترنت موجوده على
الاقل وعليه فنصيحتي الكم ولنفسي لما
يتحدث صاحب نظريه المؤامره للمره القادمه
امامكم ما تتسرعوا وتسارعوا باسقاته يمكن
وربما فقط هو على حق وربما لانه المؤامره
ذات هذا الحجم المهول فاحنا لم نتمكن من
رؤيهها جميعا والقلائل الذين يروها
والقلائل اللي قادرين انهم يروها بشكل
واضح احنا بنوصفهم دائما بانهم مخابيل او
مجانين عشان هيك الرساله يمكن لن تصل ابدا
هذا كلام منطقي على العرب يبرودكاست وانا
راويه العلمي اشكركم ودمتم دائما بامان
باذن الله
[موسيقى]